depuis le début de la pandémie on
constate que la crise a un effet
économique plus grand pour les femmes
que pour les hommes chez les 25-54 ans
le taux de pertes d'emploi des femmes
est deux fois plus élevé que celui des
hommes les femmes se retrouvent en plus
grand nombre dans l'hôtellerie la
restauration le commerce de détail les
services personnels avec nous francine
décary de l'institut de recherches et
d'études féministes de l'uqam bonsoir
madame décarie bonsoir mais c'est fillon
est ce qu'on comprend bien en ce moment
dans la société en général au
gouvernement mais dans la société en
général est ce qu on comprend bien que
les femmes sont vraiment les plus
touchés par la crise actuelle selon vous
je sais quand tu es vous répondrais
suffisamment je pense qu'il ya des
efforts qui ont été faits en ce sens si
vous venez du chemin d'annoncer une
mesure qui va corriger quelque peu une
situation qu'on déplore depuis longtemps
et qu'on a connu avec un certain des
fois la veurdée des derniers mois à
savoir que les personnes qui s'occupent
de nos proches de nouveaux parents et
des personnes vulnérables dans la
société sont quelquefois pays ou si peu
que 15 $ l'heure alors effectivement ça
nous a mis à réaliser je pense que dans
l'ensemble le public et le gouvernement
le sait aussi
cette année à réaliser à quel point la
situation des femmes du point de vue
économique est encore très précaire
parce que elle se concentre encore dans
des secteurs de l'économie où il s'avère
sont moins intéressants dans des
secteurs d'économies qui offre moins de
mobilité et dans une certaine mesure en
ce moment elles sont largement dans des
secteurs qui sont touchés directement
par la pandémie alors non seulement
elles sont nous invente nature difficile
je ne dirais pas un quand naturel mais
sont nos proches à bandes
non seulement elles sont les ailes sont
dans les fonctions de soutien dans les
hôpitaux dans le ch et ses idées dans
les maisons ou d'accueil mais en plus
elles sont aussi des enseignants
actuellement et au primaire et au
secondaire
parle peu mais vous savez que 90% des
femmes s'entendent pas enseignante au
primaire et plus de 60% secondaires dont
elles sont dans des secteurs très
vulnérable thiellement est très
stratégique et dans une certaine mesure
cela reflète des choses qu'on suit
depuis toujours sur deux appareils
féminin sous évaluation des performances
et miné et surtout c'est ce que révèle
où cette sexy confinement les femmes
dans des secteurs plus fragile de
l'économie
les femmes sont essentiellement
concentrées à près de 50% dans les
emplois de service vendeuse technicienne
en informatique
esthéticienne etc elles sont concentrées
dans les emplois donne des enseignements
et elles sont concentrées dans les soins
aux personnages dans ce contexte l'heure
déjà sur le marché du travail elles sont
vulnérables et est rendu le caire et
dans le comté de l'académie actuelle le
sont encore davantage puisque
effectivement en tant que responsable de
l'unité familiale le plus souvent pour
le bus suivant malgré des changements je
voudrais pas qu'on interprète ceci
commune en disant que les hommes n'en
faut modifier leur comportement à
l'intérieur ce domestique du du ménage
mais on sait encore par exemple que les
mères de jeunes enfants furent qu'une
heure et demie de travail d'entretien et
de soins de plus que les hommes par jour
en bout depuis ce ça ça représente
qu'ils semaine de 35 heures mais sait
quelle semaine de 35 heures qui sont
retirés ou si de la possibilité de
pouvoir être sur le marché du travail de
façon rémunéré donc dire que la pression
augmente et que l'inégalité qui existe
entre les hommes et les femmes est ce
qu'on pourrait dire qu'il grandit durant
cette crise mais un risque en train de
s'agrandir vous n'avez mentionner les
femmes sont plus susceptibles de mettre
au chômage que les hommes elles sont
aussi
je ne veux pas me répéter mais sont dans
les emplois comme ceux de serveuse
devant boys dans les grands magasins
d'esthéticienne de 10 personnes vous au
service de la santé des femmes elles
sont mauvaises et akitaka retarderont
actuellement à reprendre une activité
donc elle perdre des revenus et on peut
craindre aussi que si le confinement
duré que 6 des enfants reste largement à
la maison et ou secondaire on sait que
ce sera le cas
elles ont des activités de gardienne de
d'encadrement à remplir à la maison ce
qui généralement est une activité que
les femmes en crise elle même on appelle
ça la charge mentale mais là moi j'ai
toujours pas remis de double tâche
d'huile a suivi j'ai parlé de triple
parc il ya est ce que le télétravail je
veux vous poser une autre question si
vous permettait ce que le télétravail
bien faciliter le quotidien des femmes
ou vient amplifier leurs tâches
quotidiennes il pourrait dans des
circonstances normales selon le choix
que les chiffres aient facilité la tâche
mais en ce moment je pense que ça vient
amplifier les difficultés puisque
effectivement comme je le disais on
passe la double tâche à la triple tâche
puisque maintenant il faut faire du de
l'action pédagogique il faut faire de
l'encadrement il faut faire du
divertissement avec ses enfants et donc
pour les jeunes mères il ya possibilité
aussi qu'elle quitte la emploi de
pouvoir si vous voulez rejoindre les
exigences kit oppose une immense
responsabilité
comment est-ce que vous entrevoyez cela
dit à partir de maintenant la relance
économique est ce que les femmes vont
profiter de la reprise graduelle et de
la relance économique
ben je sais maintenant je ne voudrais
pas m'avancer trop mais je vous ai fait
que jusqu'à maintenant les mesures
gouvernementales à nancy sauf pour ceux
qui étaient du soutien aux maisons
d'hébergement pour les femmes
susceptibles d'être victimes de violence
conjugale où on ne voit on ne voyait pas
jusqu'à aujourd'hui que ce qu'on parle
d'une bonification du
salaires des préposés à l'entretien à
nous proposer dans les hôpitaux
- meilleur jeu
je n'avais pas vu jusqu'à mettre balle
de mesures pouvant faciliter leur retour
au marché du travail ou des cons ou leur
assurant des compensations des
compensations qui sait via dans les
circonstances
mais le problème est toujours
effectivement d'essayer de voir comment
réduire la charge qui est imposée aux
fins et assurer leur bien-être
économique parce que vous savez les
femmes ne sont pas simplement des des
travailleuses d'appoint dans la majorité
des ménages québécois maintenant le
deuxième salaire est une nécessité et
dans bien des cas prévient la pauvreté
dans il ya lieu de considérer et de
repenser l'ensemble des effets
systémiques de notre histoire et donne
des conjonctures et de la façon dont on
va jusqu ici envisagé de travail féminin
et c'est peut-être le bon moment de le
faire ça va peut-être nous ouvrir les
yeux là dessus on s'arrête si madame
décarie merci beaucoup
mais cette visite au revoir